another round of powerful storms is
expected to bring more rain and
potential relief from the wildfires
burning in the west utility crews
trimmed trees and loose branches in
northern california friday as they clear
up from a previous storm and prepare for
the next flash flooding is a major
concern in many places that were left
barren by those fires meteorologist jeff
beradelli is tracking the nation's
weather and he joins us now jeff a
little good a little bad a whole mix for
everyone yeah because we're going to see
some drought relief that's good but
there's going to be a lot of rain in a
very quick period of time and that means
the possibility of flooding it's about
to get very active the pattern doing in
about face from very quiet to extremely
active from coast to coast but
especially across the west let's go to
the weather wall and show you what you
have and first of all take a look at
this right here
there's a parade of storms and an
extremely vigorous jet stream
across the pacific ocean because of that
30 to 40 foot waves and and crashing
surf so very rough surf for the next
couple of days but
here's the good news we're going to see
some drought relief you know 60 of the
west covered under extreme drought the
worst drought in modern history but that
is about to change at least in
california where we're going to see a
little bit of drought relief and it's
because of this fire hose of tropical
moisture an atmospheric river let's send
this on over to the big board and
explain what's going on watch what
happens right here off seattle a storm
the equivalent of a category three
hurricane the strongest storm ever that
we've seen in this part of the world
believe it or not and it's going to
force a very vigorous atmospheric river
a really deep rich tropical moisture
directly into central california and
eventually into southern california the
rain gets heavy tonight and especially
tomorrow because of that debris flows
are possible on burn scars so it could
be dangerous in certain locations the
heavy rain makes its way down the
central coast tomorrow
and on monday into southern california
how much rain are we going to see this
is almost unbelievable after such
drought conditions four to eight inches
of rain just north of the bay area three
to five feet of snowfall about an inch
down in los angeles and the storm out
ahead of it means that it's not just
going to be active along the west coast
east coast too the possibility of severe
weather later tomorrow and tomorrow
night and tornadoes in the mississippi
and tennessee valley and then the storm
moves to the east coast and that's going
to set us up for a very unsettled week
ahead guys you are not going to like me
when you look at the weather here on the
east coast as we head into next week
we'll we'll schools don't like you and
we'll see what happens you let me know
next week well we'll we'll take a fire
hose of rain not a fire hose of snow
just yet okay yeah couple months the
messenger that's right we
i don't didn't we
be shot